so we've been talking about the fact
that in 2022 in the midterms for
democrats running on roe v wade abortion
rights and gun safety might actually be
a good idea why why do i say that well
it's notable because usually it's not a
good idea typically we know from polling
that democratic voters aren't
particularly motivated to vote
to come out and vote when democrats run
on gun safety but it can turn a lot of
republicans out who want to oppose what
republicans are what democrats are
proposing we also know that abortion has
been a big fundraising issue more from
the right than for the left but again
for democrats it's not a particularly
big
motivator to get democrats out to vote
particularly in midterm elections but
we've been saying maybe this time around
it is a good idea because the issues are
so in the news and americans are so
against the supreme court overturning
roe v wade and americans are so furious
and frustrated with republicans doing
close to nothing when it comes to gun
safety
so
the next question becomes okay fine
democrats may have the country on their
side on the issue of gun safety and on
the issue of abortion but but but will
democrats come out to vote on those
issues and we have new polling on
exactly that which i want to talk to you
about in a moment first really quickly
let me tell you about our sponsor my
heritage i love tracking my genealogy
and dna and there's just this sort of
reality that if your ancestors are
jewish and they were moving around due
to political circumstances
before and during world war ii
it can just be really tough to figure
out
from most records sort of like where
you're from and that's one of the great
things about the dna test by myheritage
which was able to give me a more
detailed breakdown than any other test
on the market i sent my heritage a quick
cheek swab
it opened me up to all sorts of
fascinating discoveries about my family
you get a breakdown of your origins
across 42 ethnicities in over 2100
geographic regions you can find new
family members who match to your dna i
trust my heritage with my privacy
because of their policy
of never selling or licensing your data
period
you remain the owner of your data my
results
not shockingly
98.8 percent ashkenazi jewish of origins
in poland and ukraine and russia and
romania all of which i knew about
but also hungary germany east and
central europe i did not know about that
and also 1.2
english which is pretty interesting i've
been using my heritage for years to
connect with cousins and other people
and now i also have the dna information
and it's fascinating start making
exciting discoveries about your own
origins get free shipping on your dna
kit when you use my link in the
description and use the code pacman
alright so
new polling says yes
democrats are more likely to come out
and vote in the midterms after the
supreme court's abortion ruling
on roe v wade there is a new npr
pbs
marist poll this is a very good poll
which found that 78 percent of democrats
say i am now more likely to vote in this
year's midterms because of the ruling
from the supreme court overturning roe v
wade opening the door for states to just
out and out ban abortion when asked the
same question
only 54 percent of republicans said i'm
more likely to vote in november now uh
and 53 percent of independents said i'm
more likely to vote in november so i
don't think i have to overstate the
reality that
if you have such a gap that's a 25 point
gap
okay
as of the supreme court's decision on
roe v wade democrats say i'm 70 78 say
i'm more likely to vote now
only 53 of republicans say i'm more
likely to vote that's potentially
crushing to the republican party now i
don't want to go crazy with hyperbole
and say oh it's going to be a great
victory necessarily because there's
another factor that is working against
democrats and that's that over the last
year and we'll have a report about this
on the show
there has been a significant change in
voter registration
away from democrats
towards republicans that's not good for
the democratic party so
you know i've said before
the 2014 midterms did not feel like the
most important midterms of our time they
just didn't and we covered it and we
followed it and every election is
important but i was not saying these are
the most important midterms of our time
it did not feel like a critical
inflection point the 2012 presidential
election yeah i voted for obama i didn't
want mitt romney to be president but the
truth is
it was not the most consequential
presidential election of our time obama
won easily with relatively little little
controversy fine
this upcoming midterm
really feels like
a potential inflection point
a major fork
in the next 10 years of american
political history and so we're going to
be following all of it
voter opinions about the important
issues
what democrats can or should do to get
out the vote
whether the party registration
change is going to hurt democrats all of
it but the early data
is that as a result of what's happening
in this country democrats are finding
themselves far more motivated to vote
than republicans and with midterms where
turnout is typically low
it could be of massive uh consequence
and the house and senate could quite
literally hinge on it